well that works in perfectly with
another question because we recently
heard michael c hall for QA for kill
your darlings say something very
interesting he loves it when a director
gives him notes of positive
reinforcement such as that's great but
can we add this instead of maybe the
negative of don't do that how is it that
you would address a student in front of
a group or as a teacher or as a director
what's the best way to approach someone
you know they're sensitive there in
front of an audience they're scared I
think first of all teaching and
directing or two different things and I
differentiate them I very try very much
not to direct when I teach and if I'm
going to do something that feels like a
director I will tell the student I'm
going to be directorial right this
minute but teaching is empowering your
students to be able to learn tools and
then go out there in the world and the
business and then have a certain gain of
certain independence in their work and
so therefore I wanted I want my students
to feel where that freedom feels like in
terms of giving adjustments whether I do
it as a director or whether I do it as
an acting teacher I think it's
absolutely right you have to do it in a
way it's very sensitive it takes a lot
of courage what is the show film courage
it takes a lot of courage for an actor
to get up whether it's in front of the
camera or on stage and to tell their
truth and to open up their vulnerability
it's not such an easy thing to do and so
here you have somebody that you know
becomes critical and potential becomes a
negative interject and you know little
gremlin perched on their shoulder
telling them you're not doing it right
the moment an actor I don't think can
hear that it makes them shut down it
would make me want to shut down and so
that's why you as much as possible hope
to have a collaboration either with a
director or have a teacher that is a
third eye that gives you that feedback
that is you know helps you to elevate
your performance and understand that
whatever you're doing can also be there
you know
you